I want to talk today about the issue of transgender
sports participation and maybe even more specifically
about trans women in sports, and there's a
really specific reason why I want to do this.
Last week, I got a call, and as many of you
know, when we do calls, they can be about
anything.
I'm not prepared for them.
I'm just answering.
And the topics can be anything.
And I give my thoughts at the time.
And someone called in who said they're on
the left, they're not trans phobic.
They support trans rights at every opportunity.
And yet they said they recognize that having
individuals born biologically male participating
in women's sports confers an advantage at
a physical level that didn't make sense to
them.
And I said not knowing a lot about it, that
I also didn't fully understand the logic.
But I was aware of the fact that the right
often cynically wants to make this the issue
about trans rights when the reality is it's
really not the major issue that that that
make it out to be.
And it's often used as a way to subtly push
back against trans rights more broadly.
And today, I want to expand on my comments
because I actually had some time over the
weekend to research the issue in more detail.
And the more I learn about it, the more convinced
I am that it is a fabricated wedge issue to
divide people and in particular to predispose
people to be against trans rights.
As I researched the issue, one of the things
I learned is that hormone replacement therapy,
which trans women often avail themselves of
over a one to two year period, comes close
to completely eliminating the performance
gap that we might imagine exists in some sports.
When you have individuals born biologically
male competing against those born biologically
female.
Now, I want to put aside for a second the
absolutely hysterical notion that some CIS
gendered men might, quote, pretend to be trans
women and go through testosterone blocking
treatment merely to compete in women's sports
without actually genuinely being trans.
Someone willing to do that has bigger issues
that need to be resolved.
But it's it's so uncommon that it's not really
the issue.
The reality is that a study from 2015 called
Race Times for Transgender Athletes shows
that trans women have essentially no advantage
in running over CIS gendered women after a
period of roughly a year of hormone replacement
therapy.
There's another more recent study which showed
that after one year, there is still a modest
advantage for trans women and that the length
of time with the hormone replacement therapy
maybe should be longer.
But to get from that, the idea that this is
some kind of, you know, woak kabal looking
to impose Mike Tyson or his physical equivalent
into women's wrestling against 18 year old
girls as an example, that's a cartoon that
that's ridiculous to suggest that that's predominantly
the situation that that exists in the world.
And I got a few dozen emails about this, and
I was completely genuine when I said last
week, I've not studied this enough, but at
face value, it does raise some questions for
me.
I still believe this is a complicated issue,
but the issue of trans sports is one of many
issues related to trans rights, and its importance
is being dramatically inflated by certain
groups of people for cynical political goals.
And what I mean by that is that trans people,
intersex individuals, they didn't just start
existing in the last five years, sports organizations,
endocrinologists and others, they've known
about this for a really long time.
And many institutions deal with these things
on a case by case basis.
So when I hear about a political movement
that has this knee jerk reaction to immediately
say no trans women and women's sports, period,
it either is coming from just an ignorant
place or a place of very bad faith.
So I'm glad to have learned more about it
and to be able to say more.
And that doesn't mean all my questions are
answered with a whole bunch of sports.
This is not really an issue with a certain
category of sports.
This is in theory an issue.
And we have to look at hormone replacement
therapy, actual performance differences after
one or two year periods.
And I tweeted about this yesterday and a few
people wrote to me and they said, oh, but
there's this particular case where someone's
skull was broken by a trans woman.
OK, I'm not saying that there are no issues.
What I am saying is that pretending this is
the issue about trans rights is wrong.
I'm not going to say necessarily that it's
coming from bad faith.
It could be ignorance, but it's wrong to say
this is the issue.
It has to be dealt with on a case by case
basis.
And the other thing I would point out is the
people that were replying to my.
We kept talking about the two or three individual
instances, where else would these folks say
that because of two or three instances of
something, we need to completely change all
of the legal and regulatory infrastructure,
look at the number of people that are killed
by guns.
And yet they say, oh, yeah, but I mean, you
know, a few hundred incidents, that's that's
not enough to justify changing the rules.
But yet here everybody's pointing to the same
two or three incidents over the last five
years and saying that justifies creating an
entirely new regulatory and legal apparatus.
It just doesn't pass the sniff test for me.
And I've been glad to to learn more about
it doesn't mean every question is answered,
doesn't mean that there aren't some problems
to solve or questions to deal with.
But I think we need to understand the sort
of cynical nature that exists by among those
who pretend this is the issue and use it as
a smokescreen to deny trans rights more broadly.
And unfortunately, that's what's happening
all too often.